see you around  and tell your sister i said hi of course  if i ever see her again new job's been  tough on her lately  need a little pick me up you got  chromantic or  the hell you want the swell for boss i  heard some batches even glow in the dark  why drink poison when you can drink  spunky monkey way better then  you freeze up a lot one second bus  brad hey brad listen  boss you helped me out kids on the block  been up my ass lately and you seem real  tough  might as well since i'm here lead the  way  thanks what do you think you're doing  have they lost their damn minds  thanks boss without out of teaching  now that that's over you okay uh  don't worry about it i've had worse  no good [ __ ] deadbeats up till now we  almost got used to them  but to pull a knife on one of their own  well  at least chana can focus on our job now  no one in the family ever  got as high up as her anyway  stop by whenever you around i throw in a  nice discount for you  sure thing boss thanks  you